how to make better small talk with
absolutely anyone i'm chad littlefield
but in this video i'm going to highlight
brandon stanton you might not know his
name but you probably know humans of new
york which is the movement and the
project that bran stanton created and in
this video i'm going to unpack i got to
meet brandon stanton and uh connect with
him and hear him speak and he shared
some brilliant brilliant brilliant ideas
that can help all of us get so much
better with small talk so if you choose
to watch this video to the end you will
not
be able to actually be in a conversation
that stays at small talk
[Music]
brandon stanton who's about nine feet
tall when you actually meet him in
person um so if you're not familiar with
humans of new york google it first of
all it's a wonderful little internet
rabbit hole of humanity the basic idea
is he wanted to
take photographic census of new york
city you want to take portraits of
everyone in new york city obviously
never get to everyone i don't know what
his count is up to but it's definitely
over 10 000 people at this point which
is holy smokes a lot of people this is
years and years and years of taking
people's portraits but he did it in a
really fun and unique way when he posted
the portraits to originally facebook and
other social media he would post their
photo which are all really phenomenal
showing really
eclectic diverse interesting people that
just the photo itself tells a story but
he goes one step further as he's taking
portrait of them he also asks them
questions he sparks up some small talk
and he includes with their photo just
kind of a
line from the middle of their story so
meaning a quote something that they
actually said in the middle of their
conversation now when i met him and i
heard him speak he shared the process
that he actually goes through
to get to really great parts of the
story because if you just show up to
somebody in the middle of new york and
you're like hey like tell me something
interesting about yourself it's quite
unlikely that they're going to tell you
this like really heartfelt amazing story
about their grandmother when they were
five years old
but when you pair a story about someone
who was five years old hanging out with
their grandmother and their picture is
of like a nine foot tattooed motorcycle
dude covered in leather
right the amount of depth that it gives
that person is huge and so there's lots
of value of being able to go beyond the
surface and so the way that he described
it was the helicopter method it was this
idea that a helicopter when it's landing
so when it gets to its final destination
right the rotors are spinning really
really really really fast and they're
spiraling as it's going down as it's
going down so sometimes in conversation
it kind of feels like you're in the
circular pattern but you're moving
vertically you're actually getting depth
as you're going so that's that's about
the extent that brandon stan explained
this helicopter method it was just kind
of the metaphor of like you have to dive
deeper and deeper into conversation but
me and my co-founder will really like to
think about how to ask powerful
questions and create conversations that
matter and so
we took that metaphor a step further and
said okay what does that actually mean
like
like taking it out of metaphor land what
does it actually mean to spin the blade
around and to go lower like how do you
actually do that and so to add a
metaphor think about ping pong
if i was curious about that
motorcycle guy's story with his
grandmother
i'm gonna focus on that one element and
i'm gonna toss a question like a little
ping pong ball back about that one
experience and then he'll fire back with
something and then that will spark some
new experience and it kind of ping-pongs
back and forth or in brandon's where he
spirals down the point is i'm gonna
bounce around a ton of questions maybe
to a whole handful of topics but when i
finally get low enough in the helicopter
to see my destination or see the x on
the ground or the helipad where i need
to land or in reality it's not a helipad
right it is a topic that
ignites your curiosity
the way that you eradicate small talk is
to be voraciously curious about whatever
that person has to share okay if the
helicopter and the ping pong aren't
working for you
think about when you google search
something so if you want to find
something that's really really
interesting that goes beyond small talk
let's say you want to learn all about
genghis khan you don't know a lot about
genghis khan and so you google genghis
khan what you're going to do when you
google genghis khan is you're going to
type in his name press enter and
google's going to feed back a couple
hundred million results for you and
you're going to scroll through and find
the one that piques your interest the
most and you're going to click on that
and then you're going to look around
that page there might be a couple videos
and a foot well maybe not videos of
genghis khan
a couple photos
some articles and there's gonna be some
hyperlinks there and you're gonna click
again and you're gonna go a little bit
deeper and then you're gonna click again
and this is what we call an internet
rabbit hole right you started with
genghis khan and who knows where you
ended up
if you want to get really good at small
talk stay focused on genghis khan stay
focused on one thing and keep being
curious about that and circling around
back to it connecting it to other things
right don't end up on tik-tok when you
started with genghis khan stay in the
place stay focused on whatever it is
that you're naturally genuinely curious
about and keep asking questions from
different angles to that because if you
do that you go deeper in conversation
vertically rather than horizontally
bouncing around everywhere the reason we
get off of an internet rabbit hole and
we feel like kind of exhausted and empty
is because we didn't get anywhere we
just like skimmed around on the surface
we never got to any level of depth
whereas if you spent a whole 10 hours
researching one single topic
compared to most of the population you'd
be a master at that topic and so one way
to bring out somebody's mastery is to
stay deep ask more about that so if
they've mentioned that they're a nuclear
engineer you could then ask them where
they're from and bounce over here but i
if you're curious about the engineer
part ask them how they got into that ask
them uh what one of the scariest things
they experience as a nuclear engineer
ask that right continue asking them
questions
on whatever really ignited your
curiosity i'm really transparent before
i hit record on this video
uh i said to steven my master
filmographer was like i feel like i've
recorded 17 video tutorials on how to
create small talk and yet it's a
frequently asked question because it's
so present everybody experiences it 98
of the human beings i've ever met would
be totally happy taking small talk
and swapping it out for conversations
that matter things that they really care
about or things that the people are
talking to really care about because
when you talk to somebody who's
interested and treated and passionate
it's so much better than social chit
chat because we're obligated to fill the
space i say that as an invite because if
you enjoyed any piece of this you can
get a free excerpt of our book that
dives way deeper into this but you can
also just google my name chad
littlefield small talk
and chad littlefield small yard chat
littlefieldsmalltalk and you'll get a
ton of different videos that take
different angles and share some really
practical insights and tips on how to go
from small talk to conversations that
matter i'm chad have an awesome day